PDF right age the restaurant synonymous
with classic American staples like
mozzarella sticks and loaded potato
skins a dining Oasis in suburbia but
what if the original concept of TGI
Fridays had nothing to do with that but
enter Alan Stillman my name is Alan
Dylan and I founded TGI Fridays in 1965
TGI Fridays started not as a restaurant
but a place to mingle the concepts came
about from one being about 20 years old
looking for a place to meet his many
good-looking woman it's like uh who was
New York City and the year was 1965 TGI
Friday came onto the scene as one of the
world's first singles bars
because back then it wasn't easy for
singles to meet the technique yes
applause was that during the week people
how they all go home you would organize
what would you people and you will all
end up at different cocktail parties
which basically is what TGI Fridays was
missed being a cocktail party that you
need an invitation to whether it was a
sound plan or not TGI Fridays blew up
almost instantly attracting more single
to the neighborhood than anyone could
have ever imagined
I was there what is a tending bar one of
the waiters came up to me and said first
of this half a dozen people outside that
want to come in what do we do I walked
out from behind the bar by a half an
hour later and then what 20 people
spending out there so we may have
created the first blind in the history
of the restaurant president Allen came
into this with no hospitality experience
at all I would say left him done I had a
very inventive job of restoring perfumes
at slavery Allen became so popular that
Tom Cruise's character from the movie
cocktail was loosely based on him his
character sort of was imitating what we
had done Fridays at the top he was
trained with flipping bottles and drinks
looks better than I was and when he
looks back Allen's proud of what he
created it was certainly
as far as anything that you could
possibly imagine it was really something
that was quite special
[Music]